Okay, we did a cheek swab in December and you tested my SEAC T capsules, but see my kidneys
got tender when I took them.
So I stopped.
My last cheek swab I had asked if it's a good idea for your T, I didn't see, I should take
it or not.
So if I didn't recommend that you should take it then you don't, I'm not going to say don't
take something that we test for.
So it's, it's, so if I didn't make that recommendation that I'm not recommending it.
Also after stopping the medications for metastatic breast cancer, Megan and she's talking about
Megan Van Zell here who we recommend for, to a lot of people who go through emotional healing,
she's the person we recommend that can help with that.
So Megan Van Zell, want to be checking with you to see if I should be taking mistletoe
if so, do you know or practitioner know that I did get this before your test, that didn't
come out.
So no, you don't need to do that.
Just a note, I did try this a year ago, you shots around the breast tumor and then with
the rash started injections in my stomach, usually mistletoe is an injectable in your stomach
above your belly button was told to stop due to the rash and now after listening to your
cause, this was actually a good thing.
Yeah, so if you're doing mistletoe injectables, that's how you dose it.
If you're not getting a rash, maybe they thought the rash was lasting too long, I don't know.
So I don't know the history of that, but if you're not getting inflammatory response in
the skin with your mistletoe injectable, then you're not dosing it high enough.
So that's the whole purpose of mistletoe is to stimulate a TH1 response.
But is mistletoe the right thing for everybody?
Well, don't stop the right thing for everybody, of course it is a death thing.
So I would not suggest you start that again right now.